prime minister you're announcing the ban
on Russian Diamond Imports and other
sanctions on additional for G7
individuals or companies linked to Putin
do you expect other seven countries to
follow you this weekend what's your
message to Peter Well I think the most
important thing we can do right now for
Global Peace and Security is to support
Ukraine and it's its struggle against
Russia but also to ensure that Russia
pays a price for its illegal and
unprovoked active aggression that's why
we've announced new sanctions today we
are talking with our Allied countries
our partner countries and I do expect
others to follow as they have done
throughout the last year of this where
we have often taken the lead whether
it's providing resources to Ukraine or
sanctions and we've seen other countries
partner with us because ultimately
sanctions are more effective when
they're done in a coordinated fashion
and I hope that's what we'll see here as
well okay so sanctions for Russia do you
expect this war to end next year what's
your message to Putin my message to
Putin is straightforward in when not
going away
Russia is conducted an illegal
unprovoked act of aggression by invading
Ukraine and Russia needs to know that we
in other countries remain steadfast in
our resolve to support Ukraine not just
in the here and now with the resources
it needs to defend itself but for the
long term as well and one of the topics
of conversation I'll be having and have
been having with my fellow leaders is
about the longer term security
agreements that we put in place for
Ukraine to deter future Russian
aggression and make them realize that
they should just withdraw their forces
okay prime minister why is bringing down
overall net migration numbers so
important to you because it's something
that we said we would do in our
Manifesto I know it's important to the
country but I also know that tackling
illegal migration is the country's
priority and that's why one of my five
priorities is to stop the boats part of
our ability to do that is cooperating
with other countries which is why I was
pleased this week that we've opened up
negotiations with the EU for our border
agencies to cooperate more closely and
that practical cooperation will help us
break the criminal gangs tackle illegal
migration and to help stop the boats and
prime minister's overall net migration
numbers going up or down
well we'll see when the latest numbers
are reported but my my clear goal is to
reduce the levels of legal net migration
whilst at the same time focusing
relentlessly on stopping illegal
migration and that's why one of my five
priorities is to stop the boats and what
were migration net migration numbers
last year as I said that the numbers
last year I mean you'll have them on top
of your head we're about to get new ones
and we know that numbers are too high
and I want to bring them down I've been
very clear that my goal is to bring
those numbers let's unpack it a bit
because back in 2019 the government
promised to cut my net migration at the
time it was 226 000 it's gone up it was
504 000 last year will it go down next
year oh well just just on the numbers
last year if you actually look at that
release that was put out it's very clear
that there are a set of factors which
led to those numbers including for
example Ukrainian refugees which are
included in those numbers so I think we
need to treat a little so high numbers
of foreign workers so student visas
unique circumstances relating to our
Refugee programs for bringing Ukrainian
refugees well look I'm not I'm not going
to preempt what the future numbers are
but what I can tell you is I want to
bring the numbers of legal net migration
down that's something that we said we
would do and we remain committed to
doing that we're reforming our welfare
system to ensure that we can move people
off welfare and into work I think
everyone would agree that it's far
better for our economy and far better
for people if we can do that and at the
same time as I said crucially we must
tackle illegal migration and that's why
one of my five priorities I haven't got
long um the forecast say it will
continue to climb to between 650 000 and
nearly a million if it's anywhere near
those numbers will you have failed as a
government again Beth you're speculating
on what may or may not be what I can
tell you is I am committed to bringing
the levels of legal migration down we're
very clear about that there's a range of
options we're considering and at the
same time I think people know that I'm
relentlessly focusing on stopping the
boats because the levels of illegal
migration are too high okay they've
escalated massively in the last week I
promised what I'm hearing is in 2019 you
said you would bring them down below uh
000 the tall the conservative government
last year they were five thousand five
hundred and four thousand next to their
predict this the year to June 2023 there
June 2022 so they predicted to go up to
1 million and you're not acknowledging
that at all is a problem or saying that
you might have failed as a government by
failing to live up to that commitment
for the British people at what I'm not
acknowledging is the specific figures
because we don't know them yet and it
wouldn't be right perspective
what I can say as we've already said is
that the levels of legal migration we
want to bring down I'm very clear about
that I mean I'm absolutely committed to
doing that there's a range of options
that we're looking at I do think the
numbers last year were impacted by the
fact that we welcomed Ukrainian refugees
to the UK which is something I think
well collectively let me put it this way
then let's try and get a commitment out
of you do you commit to bringing them
back down below 400 504 000 by the next
general election as I said I'm committed
to Bringing Down the levels of migration
inherited and I'm relentlessly focused
on stopping the boats that's one of my
five priorities and we're doing
absolutely everything we can to do that
too do you accept that by the next
election you might not be able to bring
them down below half a million again I'm
focused on bringing down the levels of
legal migration but I am also completely
focused as one of my five priorities of
stopping the boat and I think that is
the country's priority when it comes to
migration it's tackling illegal
migration it's stopping the boat that's
why we're passing new laws in Parliament
cooperating with other countries and
returning over a thousand I think legal
migrants I think what viewers might see
is that in 2019 though 224 000 they're
now half a million in the year to June
2021 and there probably could go up to
nearly a million next week but
um and you can't give me a figure as to
what you'll commit to but anyway let's
move well I can commit want to bring
those levels down and I think people
know that I'm working night and day to
tackle illegal migration one of my five
priorities is to stop the boats I think
people know that and that's why we're
passing new laws in Parliament I think
most people will agree that that's the
right priority all right for us you're
one of life's success stories you were
head boy at school you had a career in
finance that made you very wealthy now
you're prime minister how do you feel
when you lose
sorry how do you feel when you lose
how do you mean that
well you're a winner in life how do you
feel when you don't win well look my my
focus in this job is to deliver for the
country I've set out five very clear
priorities to hard inflation grow the
economy reduce debt cut waiting list and
stop the votes all I'm doing every day
is focus on delivering for people
against those five priorities I firmly
believe that that's what the country
wants me to do that's what the
government is committed to doing and
we're working night and day to make sure
that that happens and you lost to Liz
truss last year
um did that hurt more or less than
losing over a thousand Council seats at
your first test at the valley and it's
always disappointing to lose a
hard-working counselors but the message
I've taken as a country wants me to
redouble our efforts to deliver for them
as I said the five priorities have set
out I believe are the right ones to
halve inflation grow the economy reduce
debt cut waiting list and stop the boat
that's what the country wants us to
focus on that's what I am focusing on
day and night and I will keep at it that
that morning were you quite dotted as I
said it was just pointing to lose
hard-working conservative councilors
many of them are friends and colleagues
as well but I'm going to work very hard
to deliver for the country and I'll go
in the five priorities I've set out I
believe are the right ones those are the
country's priorities to have inflation
grow the economy reduce debt cut waiting
list and stop the votes day and night
that's what I'm focused on that's what
the government's focused on and you know
whilst things are tough I'm confident
that things will improve and people will
be able to see that we are delivering
for them and improving their lives I'm
nearly out of time but just on that
you've been saying things are
Improvement for households in the UK but
do you acknowledge many people are
having a really tough time I always
acknowledge that I always I literally
just said it as well of course it's
tough time at the moment the number one
challenge that families are facing is
with the cost of living that's why my
first priority is to halve inflation
it's why we tax the windfall profits of
energy companies last year and use that
money to pay around half of a typical
household's energy bill that support is
worth fifteen hundred pounds now we did
that because we know things are
difficult and we will keep helping
people with the cost of living and
what's your message to the father on Sky
News this week you had to steal baby
formula milk because he couldn't afford
to feed his child yeah I'm very sorry to
hear that I know things are difficult
what I would say to families in that
situation is please go and talk to your
local Council the government has made
available a billion pounds to local
Council so something called the
household support fund it is there that
money is there to support families who
are in particularly difficult
circumstances who for whatever reason
all the other support we've put in place
isn't sufficient or isn't getting to
them and there is lots of support in
place for vulnerable families and we
haven't got time to go over all the
different things now but that money is
there with your local Council please go
and talk to them awesome about the
household support fund the government
has given councils a billion pounds to
help families who are vulnerable and
need that extra help and in his shoes
would you have done the same
to comment on the particular
circumstances of many families I can
tell you what I'm doing in this job is
making sure that we've provided extra
Financial Resources to councils so that
they can help families who are in
difficult situation with a little bit of
extra help with Essentials like that I
would urge them to go and talk to their
Council because that support is there
okay prime minister thank you so much
thank you very much